[Music]
in mind-blowing sex news oh damn I
thought it was like sexual text you did
say sext which is not sex what's going
on what it's horny sexting is sex Julie
texting it's text as textually sexy
Peter Wiggins let's move on here
a woman suffered a stroke reaching an
orgasm calling causing her brain to
bleed bro I can't believe that she came
so good sometimes it feels like you
can't even breathe sometimes you feel
like she must have been trying to like
she must have been on like six or seven
because then like you just be all like
tensed up like try and make it happen
and that's what cuz I was like maybe she
was halfway leaving off the bed and then
her also like auto-erotic asphyxiation
yeah so there's like all that blood
rushing what happened what happened
maybe he was eating her out step this
way like the pornos would they have the
legs like this I was thinking that she
was doing this to herself because if a
guy did this he is so happy right now
remember that time I [ __ ] ate you out
you died wait here what oh oh you got a
stroke well how I remember because she
came back to life stupid God look at
going please I said she died she died
she died no stroke stroke of good luck
she got stuck 44 year old woman she was
mid receiving oral sex Davi got her
right oral sex
boom I thought she was getting [ __ ] wit
about plug and a vibrator on a [ __ ]
[ __ ] me because that's a that's a
hardcore organ an orgasm really depends
on the girl dude I don't need a butt
plug now we know too much about Jess she
doesn't like that stuff and ear plugs
and adults plug nose plugs
yeah during sex yeah well it's kind of
like you know how like sometimes you tie
yourself up or sometimes you put a
blindfold on earplugs like another form
of sensory deprivation try it it wasn't
really into it oh you actually tried it
baby close your ears all right like
think about it like if you're like
literally like bound like it's nothing
but like the feeling you know like it's
an it's a thought that's why I was like
I'll try it but like honestly I just got
anxious it's like I can't see you danger
you blindfolded too I think so
it would there be danger in the middle
like are you guys have anxiety I need to
be I need to be aware of my surroundings
at all times
I like how experimenting are you ever
try with like a 3d glasses on the red
and the blue one okay and then like a
projector on the ceiling wait a minute
that's an idea so that really magic I'd
[ __ ]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
crazy dude I'm [ __ ] wild bro
can you go up both ways and then go like
that and then go like that and it change
direction can you change the direction
okay sorry
take a stupid huh yes so this woman okay
so she passed out oh yeah for about two
to three minutes she that's scary
probably kept going and thought you as I
give it yeah yeah
he's thought they called the paramedic
you rushed her to the hospital he told
everybody there can you tell all the
staff back in her [ __ ] to death please
tell everybody I did that this woman is
coming in yes my name is David Berkowitz
yes she said that she felt sick when she
arrived to the hospital and that she was
suffering a really bad headache stroke
bored that headache of six out of a ten
and then a CT scan showed a burst
aneurysm she's gonna died yeah orgasms
are crazy huh happened maybe some people
just experienced and you're crazy levels
of do for you yes they're saying that
she might be diabetic too it causes a
surge and blood pressure so like
especially if she's like reaching an
orgasm like you know you just see your
brain can't take it sometimes maybe
she's a lot of salty food too
yeah maybe she has bad circulation and
she needs to do some cardio so they're
saying it was a small aneurysm does she
remember
does she you know how likes jokes make
you forget sometimes makes you forget
how to use your hand makes you forget
what words to say hmm
this is the exercise like if you had up
when you have an orgasm and if you're
like squatting like a decent amount of
weight what has more pressure to your
face in head and like orgasm more than
squatty yeah [ __ ] nevermind I'm scared
like I should work out you're squatting
you're you could still you can still
distribute like we're like breathing you
can regulate your heart rate or whatever
you know that's your maxing out I got on
ik denlon you know and if people's faces
like it about to explode all [ __ ] its
but it's it's it's pretty similar what
ya lookin crazy yeah it's pretty close
you can't you can't control it take this
[ __ ] you're everything it's tight
I've got a cramp before because [ __ ]
just flexes on well you're just so tense
you're just like you can't move they
call it the electricity damn I think
roses wait Simon guys for sure I mean
just by seeing you guys it's like that's
all that's all you get down on that side
yo there's this graph that that shows
the difference like they hooked up guys
goes to a meter and [ __ ] and in so the
guys orgasm it looks like this like it
hits so while we start pumping and
[ __ ] right we hit that more it's not
a plateau but it's like this baseline
yeah a pleasure it goes up like this and
then we hit this and then it spikes up
that's that's when we come and it goes
back down immediately for girls it's
like it's more like a pyramid it goes
like this yeah it's like it's like this
and then and this is during intercourse
though I'm not saying this is how the
orgasm works but it's like a gradual
explosion to it but it's more like a
it's it's like swivels up and it hits
the pyramid and it goes up and then it
shoots down Graduate guys is this week
girls goes like this because
the peak is a higher peak only because
they're starting from such a lower point
Lord alone yeah so so it's like they're
reaching a higher like a like a [ __ ]
rocket ship yeah well guys it's more
like we're already at midway through and
then we just need that tip of the
iceberg yeah it's just like boom and
then we just go right down it was pretty
funny when you look at the graph the
guys it's like immediately drop down
after coming where girls it's like a
gradual I was like wow Joe's so
enlightened I was like that he's figured
all this out you're like oh I looked at
the graph I'm like that makes sense do I
stop more it was in my book called the
pocket sex guide it's gonna be a number
one seller for a week but my friend pass
it to me a junior high it's very it's
very like scientific your sex life it
was like a healthy way of learning sex
not like super science in that way you
know what I thought was always weird in
those sex books there was a chart about
what men eat and how it affects the
taste of semen oh I'm in a sex ed book
that I took in college I forgot what it
was he was a psychology class but either
way they had like this thing a graph of
what foods affect the taste of semen
hi a nap was supposed to make a sweet
there was something about fruits and why
shouldn't I read that and high fat foods
makes it taste bitter or something like
that but it was in the textbook
interesting huh yeah berries I don't
know why that was so important to put
oranges pineapples was written by a
woman telling all the [ __ ] poison
probably drink some water have some
[ __ ] fruits all right yeah you want
me to swallow that nut [ __ ] have a
lot of pineapple [ __ ] bears reading
that did you ever try it a girl has
never let me nut in their mouth ever
really that's one of the greatest joys
in life ever
Dumanis I don't even care if they
swallow I mean that I think it's more
like a fetish thing it's like oh hey
Lina she wants all of me right I don't
care if they swell so for me it's just
the the feeling exciting inside it feels
good very true oh because there's like a
pan
moment where you like I'm what do I put
this it's happening where do I put this
and so with with that maybe you don't
have that moment of panic it's just like
this no no no I imagine so okay imagine
it's always better to have an orgasm
with a dick inside than with a dick
without so if you had it so it's like
this imagine what while you're having an
orgasm right orgasm with the dick inside
yeah but you mean for a female guy
so no no no yeah both right so imagine
if you're if you're having sex right and
right when you're about to come you come
and then the guy just pulls out and then
you're left there with nothing I feel
like most of the perversion for guys
though it happens during the climax that
you want to do everything nasty but
after you come you're like oh why would
I ever do that to you mm-hmm you're like
my senses come back and I'm like like
you have him on her face and you're like
yeah and as soon as you go oh I've made
your face reveal that's like what is it
dude you can [ __ ] sick you oh my god
you're gonna be so upset you come back
to your senses
and you start oh my god just let me do
that to you but during the moment get
like you want to do all that [ __ ] that
you see online
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]